the news media is extremely upset for
reasons that are in some ways
understandable and they're upset that
they won't be able to police what Tucker
says that's really what their sad about
I know that because that's exactly what
they're saying in fact that's an exact
direct quote will anybody be able to
police what Carlson says or is this the
point it's just a free-for-all I think
this is the point it is a free fall
that's what Elon Musk wants to provide
this move by Tucker May cement the idea
of Twitter as a right-wing website
oh my gosh will anyone be able to police
what he is is he going to be able to
just say things well we can't allow that
who's gonna police him she's gonna be
out there saying his opinions about
things we can't allow that
they are not trying to hide it